check out this awesome collaboration
this is the gucci and aura ring collab
if you aren't familiar with what an aura
ring is it is a sleep tracker it has
seven temperature sensors and it also
will monitor your heart rate 24 7. it
connects to your phone through their app
and not only does it track your sleep
but it'll give you daily tips on things
you can do to not only improve your
sleep but also your readiness it takes
all of your daily activities into
account which brings us to this gucci
collab so let's open this up and check
it out oh wow look at that i love that
it has this little top logo this will
let you know which way it's actually
supposed to be worn these sensors are
supposed to be worn at the bottom
towards your palm so the entire thing is
covered with the gucci logo and it has
these gold chains all around it and
inside this box which is very fancy this
is actually the charger oh my gosh even
the usbc cable has a gucci logo